hey guys welcome back to brand-new be
Rebecca on apex legends again I just
want to apologize last video I said that
there was only five tears that were
shown I didn't realize that ei
themselves actually showed all the tears
so we're gonna be going through going
from tier 1 to tier 100 and showing off
everything that's coming in the battle
past tomorrow and then we'll see what we
can get and see if it's actually worth
it or not so it was always like if you
do enjoy let's get started so first up
is tier number one and this is gonna be
the front tier skins I don't actually
know if this is for every character I
assume that's gonna be for every
character but it's pretty cool as soon
as you get the battle fast you'll be
getting a skin I'm assuming for every
legend so that's really nice at level
two we're gonna be getting some type of
brown skin for the triple take 3rd is
gonna be a stat tracker for wraiths
fourth is gonna be a hemlock skin level
5 is gonna be a little icon and 6 is
gonna be an intro clip for Bengal or
moving on we have number 7 that's gonna
be a pecs coins number 8 is another stat
tracker buffer bloodhound 9 is going to
be this gold lookin Prowler looks really
sick level 10 is just the level 10 icon
more apex coins a double xp badge I
would assume that's what that is 13 is
gonna be octane stat tracker and then 14
is gonna be a longbow skin in which it
also has the gold color like the problem
15 we have another banner 16 is in show
equipped for Mirage 17 is apex coins 18
is going to be a stat checker for life
line 19 is a Spitfire skin 20 is another
icon 21 and 22 are gonna be more apex
coins and we're double xp 3 is gonna be
a stat track for bangle or 24 is a
really shitty Mozambique skin for a very
shady weapon and 25 is gonna be another
icon and now at 26 we finally have
something different and finally
something I personally would think is a
lot cooler it's gonna be a purple apex
pack drone looking thing I do believe
that might just mean that you're gonna
be guaranteed a purple as soon as you
open that that's what my faults are
gonna be on this 27 is an intro for
Pathfinder and 28 is a stat track for
Mirage 29 through 36 are very similar to
what we've seen we have Apex coins
badges stat tracking for Pathfinder or
more icons more skins that are very
similar to the ones we've seen in the
other past tiers the only different
thing is that caustic is gonna get an
intro clip 37 through 44 very similar
again caustic is now going to be getting
his stat track at this point with two
apex coins coming with
these ranks at double xp badges I would
assume level 40 icon and a apex pack at
level 43 45 you're gonna be getting a
icon same with 50 46 is gonna be an
intro clip for Gibraltar
47 is gonna be apex coins 49 is a
peacekeeper skin and 48 is going to be
either octane himself or a skin for
octane I would assume I would assume
this is going to be a skin for octane
seeing as the other image that we've
seen of octane before has some type of
green color to him so that could be his
default skin so the other way let me
know you guys think this could if you
guys think this is going to be actually
octane where you get to unlock him
halfway through the pass or is it just
the skin for him 51 through 56 is a
really cool skin for the Prowler more XP
an apex pack a devotion skin intro quick
for Wraith and a 55 icon 57 through 64
we have a pax coins a stattrak another
skin for the Mastiff level 60 icon a 61
is going to be some type of banner I
don't actually know who that would be
from but it looks pretty cool
more XP more apex coins and a skinful to
be 2020 65 through 72 that's gonna be
two more ranks at 65 and 70 more XP more
apex coins and other banner and more
skins and an intro equip very similar to
what we've seen in the past tier so far
73 through 80 is very similar to the
past 175 and 80 being the icons 79 being
a skin for the wingmen 74 being a skin
for the r99 which is cool I like the r
99 personally but the skin is not really
my taste
73 they're gonna give you an apex pack
and 76 will be getting some type of
intro equipped for Octane's that's cool
it's the first one I think we've seen
this whole pass
81 through 86 we have an apex pack at 83
and at 86
I think 86 is gold so I'm assuming that
means you're gonna be getting some type
of guaranteed legendary so that's really
nice to see with more icons XP and skins
as well 87 through 94
same deal skins banner frame icons XP
packs drones very similar to the past
ones we've had and 95 300 which I talked
about in my last one which is a
legendary skin for the havoc a skin for
the are 301 carbine banner frame icon
intro clip and apex cool personally to
me this is actually pretty lackluster I
thought this was going to be pretty
intense seeing as its season 1 and they
got a hype up their first season because
if they don't do it right the first time
people are going to be thinking about
the past seasons the OK season 2 is just
gonna be a shitty personally to me I'm
not really a big fan of this in terms of
rewards I'm glad that we do have a
battle pass and I'm glad season 1 is
going to actually exist and we're not
waiting multiple weeks for it but I
still think that the rewards could have
been a little bit better seeing as that
at tier 99 we have a skin for the AR 301
carbine which is a skin that you can get
for the other weapons at like tier 5 but
it just happens to be that gun is later
in that I also don't see too many skins
for these characters either I think the
only skin that we saw was octane at 48
if this is actually a skin and then the
skins at level 1 other than that this is
pretty lackluster of a battle pass let
me know what you guys think about the
battle pass in the comments below like I
already I've said multiple times I'm not
really a big fan of it I'm still going
to grind to get these levels but
personally like I said not really a big
fan hey guys it's gonna be the end of
the video I hope you guys did enjoy if
you did make sure to leave a like
comment down below and subscribe for
more apex news content so I know that
I'm doing you guys a good service and
keeping up with all the info my two most
recent videos would be popping on-screen
you guys want to check that out what
that guys peace out and enjoy the rest
of your day
[Music]
you
[Music]